[Music]
hey listen
i've got an email yeah i always say hey
listen
you're literally sitting there with
headphones in your head or you're
driving down the road or you've got
the youtubes on in the corner you
already are listening so when somebody
says hey listen you're already listening
i realize that's
annoying so sorry about that so
we've got an email here that i want to
touch on because i love this question
it's from this guy named james it's
probably not from james childs even
though
maybe he knows that guy says
what is the difference between a
boundary and an ultimatum
i've heard you talk about both of them
but i can't figure out the difference
seems like one is good and one is bad
can you clarify
that's an awesome question
here's how i would define boundary
versus ultimatum
and they they come down to the purpose
of each one
a boundary is a way i am seeking
connection
in a healthy way it is me saying hey i
would like to remain
in relationship with you i would like to
continue to work here
i would like to have a healthy
relationship with you
and here is what i need to
stay whole and well so my boundary is i
go to bed at 10 o'clock
if we're gonna do crazy fun things if
we're gonna have this rambunctious sex
life
awesome it's gotta happen before then
because
if i don't go to bed by 10 then i've got
to get up at five take care of the kids
to do x and y and z
then it's going to cause challenges or
hey listen i want to work here but you
can't talk to me like that
that's a boundary right this is what i
need to be healthy here
ultimatum i i consider ultimatum
the the the line in the sand
right it's a power move it's not a it's
it's not a way we're gonna it's not me
trying to reach out and remain connected
to you
it is me saying no more
or i will scorch the earth around us
right so an ultimatum is
if you cross this line this is when i
disconnect from you
so an ultimatum is a statement of
disconnection this is it
no more a boundary is this is what i
need to be well
so one is is me communicating with you
hey
this is what i need for us to stay
connected and the other one is
this is the line i draw you cross this
line and we are disconnected
and i know they sound that's like you
just said the same thing
backwards think of them on so
beat up on this word right now but think
of those on a spectrum a boundary is a
conversation
about how i'm going to remain healthy in
this relationship an ultimatum says here
is the line and if you cross it this
relationship is over
i'm done i'm out i'm moving out i'm
finished
i quit right those are the difference
there one of them is
seeking connection one of them is about
power
one of them says enough so
is one good and one bad i don't know
because if if
if i'm in an abusive relationship and i
say
no more that's my ultimatum if this
happens again
i'm gone i think that's a good thing i
think that's you need to exert power in
that situation
um if you so i
i think it's all contextual right so i i
hesitate to say one's good and what's
bad
they're just you use them in differently
in different situations when you find
yourself in a work environment
they begin to take your soul from you
begin to look back step back and say
here's what i need to work here
hey i'm not gonna go to war with you
boss
but if you need me to be here 24 7 365
i i can't i can't do that so i i wish
you the best of luck i'm gonna go find
me another job
right am i gonna hate you am i gonna say
mean things about you in the internet
i'm gonna go find another job
right um or in a relationship hey look
um
you keep coming home at midnight you're
not texting or calling like
man that makes me feel not safe that
makes me feel like you've got more
other priorities that aren't me
here's what i need to feel safe in this
relationship i need you to at least let
me know
i need you to let me know where you are
i need you to let me know if you're
going to stand me up on a date
that's different then if you stand me up
again this is over
boundaries versus ultimatum